it's not like i can explain in two
seconds why i think this is good but my
intuition is suggesting this move
and that is queen takes e4 sacrificing
the queen for a rook and a piece
now
let's do it it's risky but let me try to
explain why i think it's good basically
the point is that this pawn on d3 i
think is so strong
that the fact that we have a lot of
pieces to support it uh i i feel like
this pawn is going to prevail over the
queen i also feel like white is
really really passive in the resulting
position and in the long run he's gonna
have a hard time restraining the spawn
[Music]
or block against the 1676 so
very strong opponent e4
okay e5
all right knight f3 knight c6
this is all
national bishop c4 yeah so
here's the thing
um
i will at some point
make opening videos
um on conventional openings i i will
eventually make kind of a repertoire
recommendation within e4 e5 for e45
and
my recommendation i'm heavily leaning
toward this
and that is the move knight f6 now most
repertoires nowadays uh most videos
recommend bishop c5 knight f6 has fallen
out of favor just a little bit
partly because of the fried liver but
also partly just because of the mainline
d3
but in my opinion for
intermediate players knight f6 is a very
practical move uh the fried lever is not
as scary as its reputation
and uh
and i just think it's uh you know
there's less tricky lines than after
bishop c5 now d4 is one of the existing
tricky lines against knight f6 this is
either the nakmanson gambit or this is
the max lang attack so
first thing we have to do
is play e takes d4 we really have no
choice
and generally black castles
okay
so here there are two main choices
if you want to play in principled
fashion then you should play knight
takes c4
that is the entrance to the max lang
attack and that is the uh entry point
into the nachmanson attack
um i'm gonna take it i'm gonna play
principal chess
but in a previous speedrun game
uh i played a much tamer move which yes
leads to a slight advantage for white
but if you don't want to get into theory
a pretty solid move here is to go d6
just advance the pawn to d6 prevent e5
now yes white recaptures on d4 and black
is a little bit passive because this
bishop has no choice but to position
itself on e7 but if you want to play you
know if you want to get the game out of
theory then d6 is a reasonable option
but in this game i'm feeling pretty
principled today let's take on e4 and
see what he's got
if he plays the nachman sen i literally
spent yesterday analyzing the nakmansen
in depth unfortunately he doesn't he
goes rookie one
now
uh we have to play d5 obviously i mean
clearly the knight is attacked we played
d5 and it looks like black is up two
pawns and dominating but this is the max
laying attack but bishop takes d5 green
takes d5 and now the knight comes out to
c3 if you're seeing this for the first
time you might be shocked but this has
been around for over 100 years
and the point of course is that what we
cannot take with the knight because it's
pinned and we can't take with the pawn
because we lose our queen so we have to
move our queen because also the queen is
attacked and white recaptures the knight
with big pressure along the e file now
the max lane attack
is not a dangerous opening it used to be
extremely popular
a hundred years ago
but uh black has found many uh viable
systems against the max lang and the
theoretical evaluation of the max lang
is totally quality
white is not actually worse as far as i
know in the main lines
but uh white is certainly not better and
black has several ways to achieve total
equality now
here's the thing guys disclaimer i
haven't analyzed this in a while i
remember what i was taught years ago and
that's what i'm going to play here queen
a5 and queen h5 are both possible moves
queen d8 i don't think is a good idea i
think it's a little bit too passive i'm
going to play queen h5 because that's
what i was taught
and the queen on h5 is of course on a
very safe square
it's x-raying the knight on f3 which
is never a bad idea in such positions
and i think it's a little less common
than queen a5 so hopefully we can throw
him out of theory the first moment our
opponent takes i think rook takes e4
check already is unfamiliar to me i
am only familiar with knight takes e4
and we'll talk about that after the game
rook takes c4 i'm sure is a move but
let's start thinking independently now
how should we even think about this
position well the first thing to
understand folks is that
both king side and in some situations
queen side castling is on the table
okay
and
okay how do you orchestrate each well
you can play bishop e7
uh that's that's viable
and very likely in that position i'm
assuming that our opponent is going to
play knight takes d4
offering a queen trade now let's think
about what happens
after the queens are traded queen takes
d1
knight takes d1
so
in that position
oh wait a minute
i've spotted something really cool
in that position we could try something
really interesting
what am i what am i implying bishop e7
knight takes d4
queen takes d1 knight takes d1 what do
you guys see
what can we do in that position
now what should you notice here you
should notice that the knight on d4 in
that position what is it defended by
folks
what is it defended by what is defending
it after the queens are traded well it's
the rook on e4 right
and i mentioned this many times rooks
and queens are very very bad at
defending other pieces because they're
easy to attack that should be ingrained
in your head now is the move bishop f5
well no because remember there is a
knight on d4 that knight can simply
capture that bishop
but what about the move pawn f5 okay can
the knight capture on f5 well no we
still have a bishop on c8 it's defending
the pawn hopefully everybody can
visualize that position now after f5 the
rook has to move but it can't move just
anywhere it has to move along the fourth
rank
let me repeat this line bishop e7 knight
takes d4
queen takes d1 knight takes d1 f5
now can the rook move to h4
no because we have a bishop on e7 it's
guarding that square the rook's only
square is f4
and in that position can we chase the
rook again
yeah we can we can play pawn g5 the rook
is out of squares and white is going to
be forced to give up an exchange so i
actually believe that bishop b7 is the
best move even though initially i myself
was was leaning toward bishop e6 and i
think bishop b6 gives a pretty big
advantage
uh but i want to test this line out and
see what he's got let's go bishop b7
and
at this level you know 15 1600 you need
to start calculating actively you need
to start calculating lines of this
length and unfortunately all of it is a
waste because it goes 92 which probably
is correct but i'm still glad don't make
no mistake i'm still very happy that we
calculated this i feel like that was a
very good very good practice okay
so
92 is good it prepares to take on d4
with the e2 knight so ideally
we would find a move that somehow
reinforces this pawn but our options are
greatly limited by the fact that we're
not castled yet
so
i think a lot of you are probably
thinking about bishop f5 in this
position but
in my view that's not a very good move
bishop f5 is not a great move here
um and neither is pawn f5 and actually
for the same reason
yeah queen the move i would play here is
queen to d5
yeah the problem after bishop f5 is the
knight swings to g3
attacking the queen simultaneously and
you know putting pressure on the bishop
so i don't particularly like that
sequence of events let's play the move
queen to d5
what is the purpose well we're getting
the queen onto a central square we are
attacking the rook
and we are adding another defender to
the d4 pawn now white has a very good
move in this position i'm not going to
say it
let's see if he finds it
and
this correct move will essentially
compel us to repeat the position
but let's test him let's test them
yeah you guys are seeing it very nice
sharp
very shut up
we contact upon a castle and he goes
knight g3 so our gamble pays off after
knight c3 would have simply repeated
moves
okay
so
what do we do now well
our pawn on d4 is still hanging
but
and this is a pretty important but
let's imagine that we make a random move
let's imagine that we castle okay
what do you see after knight takes d4
because what i see is the fact that we
will be pinning that knight
and that creates a massively compromised
situation for white so again just like
in the scenario where the queen trade
if we can chase the rook away from e4
we quite possibly are going to be able
to at the very least uh win that knight
on d4 or maybe win a pawn somehow and we
can do that by playing the move
f5
hmm but that's still not the end of the
story
let me think about this for a second
there there there there's actually a lot
of complex lines in this position
there's there there
yeah we can win upon there
geez
let's do it so let's castle
let's castle
of course we could start with the move
f5 but that's a little bit weakening i
don't necessarily want to play the move
f5
okay so he goes c3 every at every turn
our opponent like deviates from what i
think
uh
from what i think they
they're gonna play
okay
so what now what should we do now well
c3 again reinforces the pressure on the
d4 pawn
so we need to decide what we're going to
do about this pawn
and the obvious move here is d3 this is
the kind of move i would play
automatically in a classical game
and d3 just looks really sexy because
that pawn
it's not going to be that easy to attack
and here's my logic folks even if white
ends up winning this pawn back
i would argue that the tempe and the
energy that white spends to win the
spawn back is going to allow us to bring
our other pieces into the game so it's a
win-win we lose that pawn at the end of
the day hey we've got the two bishops
perhaps we can get this bishop into g4
if uh if they go rookie three
and uh
okay h3 our opponent doesn't seem
concerned in the least with that pawn
so
what should be our follow-up well our
top order of business i think you would
agree with me
should be to reinforce that pawn
now didn't i just say that we don't mind
losing it well we don't mind losing it
but that doesn't mean we want to lose it
that doesn't mean
you know we shouldn't try to defend that
pawn when given the opportunity so
there's two big priorities here that's
number one
and i think the second priority is to
complete our development to develop this
bishop i don't know why you guys are
proposing bishop f5 because after knight
takes f5 queen takes f5 we lose the pawn
on d3 so there we're essentially forcing
white to take our pawn
where should the bishop be developed not
f5 rather the bishop should come out to
e6 so either bishop b6 or the way i want
to play is rook to d8 let's get this
rook into the game let's reinforce our
defense of the of the d3 pawn
does that make sense
oh queen takes e4 oh you guys are right
i blundered that oh geez
no i did well
look i blundered that but i have an s6
sense because i think bishop f5 is still
bad but not because of knight takes f5
because of the preliminary preliminary
c4
i wasn't get i was like why are you guys
proposing this on mass
um i stand corrected i apologize it's
been a long day
okay so now that changes things to
bishop f5 is definitely a possibility
but after bishop f5
um what i'm worried about potentially is
the move c4
but now bishop f5 is obviously good even
if i didn't see
even if i didn't see queen takes you for
bishop f5 now is a good move because
after knight takes f5 we can also play
queen takes f5 the pawn on d3 is
protected by our rook
i apologize for that that was
what now he goes c4
okay
now here we have a very very interesting
idea
that
you know i haven't really played ideas
of this level of positional complexity
yet in the speed run
who can and this is not an idea that's
tactical in the sense that it's not like
it wins on the spot
it's not like i can explain in two
seconds why i think this is good but my
intuition is suggesting this move and
that is queen takes e4 sacrificing the
queen for a rook and a piece
now
let's do it it's risky but let me try to
explain why i think it's good basically
the point is that this pawn on d3 i
think is so strong
that the fact that we have a lot of
pieces to support it i i feel like this
pawn is going to prevail over the queen
i also feel like white is
really really passive in the resulting
position and in the long run he's going
to have a hard time restraining the
spawn so i've made this sort of
very snap intuitive judgment and guess
what
we are giving away the pawn on c7 as
well i don't care about that pawn what i
care about is the pawn on d3 as long as
we keep this pawn as long as we keep our
pieces active i think that we're going
to have excellent compensation for that
pawn
and this is a one could say a positional
queen sacrifice our first of the
speedrun
are very important to realize here first
of all
we don't need to hurry we can play
normal moves here we can improve the
position normally just because we've
sacked the queen for a rook and a piece
we have a lot of material for the queen
we don't need to do anything ridiculous
so
moves like rook d8 come to mind what
about this bishop guys where can it go i
like bishop f6 let's get this bishop
onto the long diagonal let's start with
that move because we don't know exactly
where the rook is going to go maybe
we'll want to put the rook on e8 that's
the thing
in fact i think
i've spoken truth to the position
because
queen d2 what is the drawback of this
move start thinking about it what what
does this move
leave what does this move leave
undefended well what do you notice look
around the position what enticing option
do we now have
absolutely let's take this knight let's
ruin white's pawn structure and now this
knight has the possibility of coming
into d4
now the immediate knight d4 ladies and
gentlemen is a blunder
very very common blunder because after
queen takes d3 it turns out that black
has no good discover checks but first we
need to play a very patient move
but not rook d8 i don't like rook d8
because there's no need
is white going to attack this pawn with
anything other than the queen
no so that's not an official use of our
resources where does the rook belong it
belongs on the open file that has just
been created rook e8
we have to beat white to the punch
because if white goes rookie one we are
going to gladly trade rooks
and that's essentially going to leave
white with very little resources uh with
which he can defend this pawn on d3 he
goes right d1
now
we can obviously infiltrate to e2 that's
essentially begging to be played right
and we're making a lot of progress here
queen back to c1
well there's a move that once again is
begging to be played
and we don't necessarily need to hurry
to play it
we don't necessarily need to hurry to
play it
i would consider our options here the
move d2
move d2
is
extremely
tempting
you know what
i think we should play it
let me think let me let me do some
calculation here
yeah i think we should we think we
should play it i think we should go d2
folks
this is i'm sorry but this is too
tempting because we're so close to
winning the game with rookie one check
and this knight is coming into d4 as
well i feel like our pieces are so
active that we have we should be able to
prevail here
okay
well what do we do now now you just have
to find the right order to do things and
again do not rush with the move rookie
one check if you play rookie one check
white simply drops the king up to g2
and we haven't won the game just yet so
the best thing to do is to turn the dial
to the maximum can we activate our
pieces to the absolute maximum in order
to make our job easier yes we can well
i've already pointed this out we can
play the move knight d4 get this knight
centralized queen a4 excellent move by
our opponent though
okay
so
let me think about this
i don't think we need to do anything
special i think we can just drop a rook
back to d8
yeah let's get let's get a rook back to
d8
no need for anything extravagant here
no need for anything extravagant here
and white is hanging by a single thread
obviously a single blunder and he loses
the game on the other hand if we lose
the d2 pawn then we lose the game so
you know i've taken a pretty big risk
here in this game
pretty big damn risk
and
i'm not positive that this is
objectively sound but i feel like it'll
work out that's another excellent move
though
okay
now what i notice about this is that the
rook i need to now x-rays
now x-rays
the the king so what i immediately see
is that we can try to get this knight to
the e3 square do you guys see what i'm
saying now can we go knight c2
well no we can't but we can go knight f5
and try to stick this knight where it
hurts on e3
our bishop's also defending the rook
indeed so we don't have to really worry
about anything back rank wise
okay we're trying to make progress
trying to poken prod
another excellent move that bishop f4
but i think i have a really really
strong reply
i think i found something extremely
strong here
anybody see what i'm talking about
wait a minute there's also this
oh there's also something really cool
here
yeah g5 very good guys g5 get the bishop
out of there just get it out of there
and if bishop takes d2 yeah white can
give up a bishop for the pawn but then
we're going to have an overwhelming
amount of material for the queen right
we're gonna have a rook a knight and a
bishop for the queen and look how weak
the king is look how flimsy these pawns
are surrounding the king do you see that
we can play bishop d4 later and attack
the spawn essentially we can go for a
checkmating attack in the event that
white takes on d2 i simply don't see a
move here for white i don't see a move
for him
i mean maybe there's something crazy
but
i don't really see much that white can
do here because if the bishop drops back
then we go knight e3 check
the bishop takes the pawn we already
established that black is winning
bishop c7
okay that's a very encouraging sign it's
not as scary as it looks what should
black do
what should black do
and don't tunnel vision this guys
especially those of you who are less
experienced what you shouldn't do is say
oh my rook is attacked i need to move my
rock don't forget about what your
intentions were so let's remember why i
put the knight on f5 to begin with where
were we going where were we going again
why was i putting the nine on f5
i was going to e3
doesn't that blunder the knight no
because we're pinning the king what's
the purpose of knight e3 well we're
getting to this rook and if we can
eliminate the rook from d1 we are going
to be one step away from promoting the
pawn right
so here it's a classic case of est equal
or stronger threat we ignore the threat
against our rook we pose a much stronger
threat this also happens to be a check
so first of all bishop takes d8 isn't
even possible
okay g5 also made luft so we don't have
to worry as much about backrank checks
as well
all right this is a great move king g3
all right
let me think
i think i see the winning line i just
need to verify
yeah
i see the win
okay so
taking the rook on d1 feels right now
let's calculate
if black takes work on d1
white takes the rook on t8
what should black do in that position
and again eyes on the prize what's the
main priority in that position the
priority is to promote the pawn well
what do we need to do to promote the
pawn well we will need to move the
knight away from d1 what's the most
efficient way to move the knight away
from d1 where should we go
and notice guys that the rook on e2 is
going to guard the e8 square that's very
important that means queen e8 which
otherwise would have been a huge problem
isn't a problem at all knight takes me
to excellent calculation knight takes b1
it takes down bishop takes f8 sorry can
i get my squares right bishop takes d8
knight takes b2
we can play this move safely and
confidently and knowing that this is
winning the game because we're hitting
the queen the queen has to move the
queen has no squares from which he can
even threaten anything as far as i can
tell
queen a7 queen d7 all of this is a paper
tiger and i'll tell you more we don't
even necessarily have to rush with
promoting the pawn
but we will promote the pawn and once we
make a once we make a queen or upper
rook in a piece
the game is over
what if he took the knight first so you
tell me guys what would have happened if
queen takes d1 happened the move is
actually very very simple
because notice that both rooks are
defending the pawn on d2 which means
that one of them can go on to do greater
things we just go rookie one but rookie
one very classic technique you dislodge
the queen from d1 once the queen moves
out of the way then you promote your
pawn
and if white takes the other rook it
doesn't matter you take the queen then
you move the rook out of the way and you
promote
that was i'll put it this way those
people checking with stockfish that was
a game with a lot of mistakes i was not
at my best
i'll be upfront and admit it probably a
lot of mistakes that you can find but i
think the queen sacrifice was
objectively sound
i'm gonna make i'm gonna advance that
theory
i'm not too satisfied might play in the
opening but i think the queen sacrifice
made this game really interesting
okay good game by our opponent too very
uh very well played he was playing fast
but
certainly um
certainly not badly
okay
yeah we can check with the engine
um i guess i'll violate my my rule i'm
not analyzing with an engine
but we can we can check with an engine
just because this game was so complex
that
i i don't mind in this particular
instance if you guys if you guys want
so i'll check the accuracy and then
we'll go through the game quickly with
an engine okay well 78.8 was not
terrible accuracy but i think there were
a lot of mistakes here okay so let's see
where they were and then we'll delve
into the game
that sack wasn't sound well i guess i'm
wrong then
okay so rookie four is a mistake already
bishop b7 is good now notice that it's
saying both bishop b7 and bishop e6 is
is good right bishop e6
knight d4
the point is after knight takes queen
takes two one knight takes one this is
what i was hinting at folks we can
castle queenside and the issue for white
is that this knight is pinned
white can defend the knight with bishop
b3 white does not lose material here
and this is why i don't like to analyze
with an engine let me explain why i
i'm a opponent of doing this because
let's say that you don't have me to
explain stuff and you're analyzing alone
you're looking at this it's saying minus
one so you're following the line you're
saying can knight takes d4 rook takes d4
bishop e7 well can you explain to me why
this is -1
because i can sure as i'll explain why
my move was minus one because basically
knight takes d4 loses an exchange
otherwise white's down the pawn but can
you explain why this is minus one are
these two the same
my rooks are better and connected i
don't think it's that though it's
basically the combination of the two
bishops together with the way that they
are placed
right it's the bishop pair the fact that
this bishop is coming to f6 and white
doesn't have time to consolidate
um white doesn't have time to
consolidate for instance if he goes with
knight c3 go bishop f6
and it's the combination of our control
over the file together with our bishop
slicing through the entire position this
is a much better end game
so but still i feel like the engine
sometimes oversimplifies these things
but we played bishop e7
and again the point is that after knight
takes d4
queen takes d1 knight takes d1
we have f5
and after rook f4
i was going to play g5
the engine is not the biggest fan of
this move
and the reason why as you can see is
very interesting the engine claims that
after knight takes c6
gf knight e7 king e7 bishop f4 white has
uh
essentially sufficient compensation for
the chain which makes sense because
white has a pawn for the exchange this
knight is coming out to e3 does
everybody see how well white's minor
pieces are placed the rook is going to
come to e1 these pawns are also quite
flimsy
so black is a small advantage here but
nothing major
um
so
this is perhaps not even the best move
stockfish
again likes the possibility of taking
and going bishop f6 just aiming for the
bishop pair
now starfish is not as materialistic as
it used to be probably stockfish five
would go would immediately say g5 but
this is one area where computers have
expanded their quote-unquote brains
tremendously
white is not easier to play i disagree
with that i think black is much easier
to play
i still would take black
15 times out of 15 here
um bishop b6 you can get your rooks into
the game but white can hold on if he's
careful engines value the bishop bear
quite highly also so knight e2
alright so now we played queen d5 which
is a decent move
and i was testing my opponent because
obviously
he can go knight c3 and i would have
repeated moves with queen h5 and then
perhaps we would have played something
differently
um
apparently the top move is queen
to g6 the same idea to attack the rook
but from a different square
and after knight g3 you go bishop e6
and again the point is that knight takes
d4 is met with long castles and
everybody should see how unpleasant this
is we we just saw a very similar
position in an endgame where white is
tied down a head to foot black is the
two bishops
uh queen is perfectly placed on g6
overseeing the entire position
uh this is this is very very good for
black so queen g6 was very strong
but okay we played queen d5
and our opponent played knight g3
okay so here we castled
so far everything i've done has been
good c3
and d3 is correct look at that
h3
and rook d8 is correct again so so far
we're playing pretty much perfectly
bishop f5 is correct once again
okay maybe this game is not so bad as i
thought
and folks i completely forgot about
rook being hanging just shows you that
even i hallucinate sometimes right it's
not like i've hacked the formula for
figuring out you know for detecting
every hanging piece but bishop f5 is
still bad
it still allows the move c4 and although
i can sacrifice my queen here and maybe
i would have done that if the queen
drops back to d7 it's no longer making
contact with the rook after knight takes
f5 white
restores material equality
okay
so
for that reason we decided on going rook
t8 to reinforce the pawn bishop f4
bishop f5 c4 and of course this is a
critical moment the engine is saying
that we should simply drop the queen
back to d7 and black is almost winning
just because the pawn on d3 is so well
defended now white's position is on the
verge of collapse but i couldn't resist
i couldn't resist
and i took on e4
and from an objective perspective this
is of course a mistake it's giving a
slight edge to white after this move
so one could argue that this is
completely unnecessary
and and that queen d7 is the move that
any normal human should play
but again i would push back on the
computer just a little bit and i feel
like
this is from a practical perspective an
interesting idea nonetheless
and maybe it's unsound but i did want to
illustrate the sort of general concept
of positional sacrifice because
this is one of the most complicated
positional notions
but nonetheless if you're 14 1500 you
have to start getting the hang of
various positional concepts such as
maneuvering
and positional sacrifices among those
things you have to understand why some
players give away upon or even give away
a piece or in some very rare cases give
away a queen
when the compensation doesn't seem all
that immediate
does that make sense
so i want to give you an example
of a game my coach showed me many years
ago
which
you know is a perfect example of just
such a sacrifice which the computer
disapproves of strongly
but from a human perspective it's a
fantastic illustration of how powerful
these these uh exchange positional
sacrifice can be
this is the
uh handwritten version of mastering
positional chess
which i started around
like 2006 maybe
and in the first
page of that book which i titled road to
positional improvement this is
well before
i knew that this was going to be
you know well before i knew that this
was going to turn into this
so i didn't start writing it with the
intention of publishing and i just
started collecting notes
i called it road to positional
improvement
and the text reads
this is about 2006. i'm not an expert at
positional play
and this book will help me improve
positionally so i was writing a book but
i was like doing it for myself
i tend to go for forced lines and i'm
very impatient this is like my coach
speaking
the solution to this problem consists of
four parts namely
look at games of gm's patron karpov etc
go over doretsky's book positional play
play training positions on positional
themes solve positional exercises
as of now i would like to show a game
which had a big impact on me and it's
actually this game you can see
the opponents
here
it's this it's this game
so i gave the whole game just as a as an
inspiring inspiring moment
now what was so inspiring about this
game sorry that i'm going on a tangent
in this position um
black is up a couple of pawns
and circle off plays a move
that appears to be a terrible blunder
he plays the move
pawn to b6
and you might look at this and say well
this makes a lot of sense he wants to
develop his only undeveloped piece who
can tell me who the keen tactical eye
can tell me why this looks like a
horrible blunder
yeah so
knight f6 or knight d6 white plays
knight f6
knight d6 is not as accurate because
black can take on d6 with the bishop
and then after bishop before the queen
has squares but after knight f6 the
bishop has to remain on c5 g takes f6
bishop b4 and the queen is trapped
but black had seen this and had prepared
a positional queen sacrifice watch what
sokolov does he goes f5
he actually says go take my queen
and this position is essentially
from a practical perspective i think
winning for black
and it's not so easy to explain why that
is but essentially black has so many
pawns and black's position is so solid
that even with an extra queen
white has no way to make any kind of
inroads on the other hand black has a
very very clear plan
that ultimately results in very smooth
victory first of all look at this
outpost look at this look at this piece
on t5
this bishop is going to come out to b7
okay
and then black is going to pile up on
the g2 pawn with everything that he's
got he's going to go rook g8
he's going to bring this other rook
anywhere along the g file he's going to
move the knight away from d5
and white is just not going to have the
ability to defend the pawn on g2 because
the queen
powerful as she is is still only one
piece
it's still only one defender this pawn
on g2 is going to be the reason that
white loses the game
watch how smoothly black does it
it should be seven
rook g8 after knight b3 a nice little
tactic bishop to e3
looks like a blunder due to rook takes
c3 but it's not because after knight
takes c3 queen takes e3 who can tell me
whether black takes with the bishop on
g2 or with the rook
avoid one move itis
avoid one move itis of course we take
with the rook not with the bishop
because its check take with the rook
because
checkmate or winning white's queen is
totally unstoppable here there's a mate
threat if you move back down the g file
or you win the queen on e3
so
white has to go g3
and now black sacks on f4 anyway
g takes f4 knight takes f4 look at this
position it's a queen for one piece and
after queen f1 white is totally
paralyzed the queen can't leave the rook
otherwise you get checkmated
so what black needs to do is get this
damn rook an a8 into the game as quickly
as humanly possible like castles
knight c5 one last ditch attempt by
white this is actually a really smart
move
does anybody understand
what the idea is of black captures on c5
who can tell me
very very powerful and smart idea by
white but sokolov is not fooled
no no no not queen b5 then you get
checkmated it's rook b1
what does white want white wants to sack
on b7 and remove the main attacker and
if you move the bishop away you actually
get checkmated in an a6
do you see that so colombia's bishop c6
my favorite part of the game he doesn't
give the bishop away
the knight has to move back to d3
now another insane move rook g4
if knight takes f4 rook takes f4 ends
the game because now the rook on f3 is
lost and everything collapses
rookie one double rooks on the g file
the game is over black is threatening
richie one check if it was black to move
here rook g1 check would end the game
takes
bishop takes f3 and it's basically mate
so white out of desperation
he takes on f4 rook takes f4 and goes
rookie three
and now another unbelievable move
now you guys might look at this and say
wait a minute what if i just take on f3
no bad terrible idea because you give up
the bishop right
sokolov the final move of the game rook
g4
threatening rook takes f3 and then
bringing the other rook to f4 queen h3
h5 shutting down the last avenue not
allowing white's queen to escape
and here white simply resigned here
white simply resigned because he's
totally in zug's van
and if the queen drops back to f1
the queen drops back to f1
then
probably black has
more efficient ways to win here i would
have to think about it
but rook takes f3 and rook f4
wins the full rook and black has a
gazillion pawns on top of it this is
completely winning by black
so
one of the most inspiring examples in my
opinion of positional sacrifice a full
queen and then a bishop is sacked on f4
and all of it for long-term play like
black understands the g-file is a
long-term thing it's not something that
can be exploited immediately
and this is why positional chess isn't
boring i can show you a million other
examples you know less glamorous
positional sacrifices petrosian
exchange sacrifices and
it's sort of you know it has to become
part of your
sort of it has to get into your blood
like various sacrifices
have to become instinctual
and the example that i like to give of a
positional sack that you should learn to
make
really without much thought
you know really without even
flinching is the following
the following sacrifice should be like
absolute second nature
logowski petrossian
um in this position petrossian
puts together an incredibly instructive
series of moves
now when you guys look at this position
what do you see
well what are white's biggest assets in
this position who can list them
what are whites what are white's assets
here what are white strings
well first of all white's got the bishop
pair right
second of all i wouldn't say white is
more space i mean space is about equal
but you should notice the b file white
has pressure potentially on the b7 pawn
but petrossian says first thing let's
deal with the two bishops now which
bishop do you want to trade
well to answer that question you need to
determine which of white's bishops is
more active well clearly it's the dark
squared bishop because the light squared
bishop is just sort of staring at its
own pawn
so let's trade the dark square bishop
all right d7
now pologoyevsky says no no no no i'm
not trading these bishops and giving the
knight a juicy square on c5
he drops his bishop back to e3 and this
is where petrosian and my guess is that
he probably spent only a couple of
minutes on this move
what did he do
yeah dark square weaknesses rook takes
e3 automatic
and i mean just look at the compensation
this is an eternal knight
you have another outpost on e5 for the
bishop
white has a terrible pawn on e3 i mean i
don't i shouldn't even have to explain
why this is good
as a
measuring point for like positional
understanding you should ask yourself
honestly like do i understand why black
is overwhelming conversation and
this is not to embarrass you like the
answer might be no and then you might
you have something to grow toward
but if the answer is yes then you're
doing well
everything is protected yeah also the b
file pressure has been canceled out by
the knight
and
if the answer is no that's a good thing
then you you know you have something to
aim toward but hopefully i basically
explained it petrossian goes rookie
eight bishop h6 piling up on the e3 pawn
and poligayevsky blunders immediately
in this position pologovsky goes with b6
and blunders knight a4 this is a top gm
just shows how powerful these things are
because otherwise white can't defend e3
so white's position is essentially lost
anyway
after rook b6 94 he resigned because he
actually loses both exchanges you don't
just lose one exchange you actually lose
the second one too the bishop takes e3
so
a pretty long detour
to i guess defend myself
but
i i guess i did want to illustrate this
concept of positional sacrifice
on top of everything else
so back to the game
what is it exactly that is wrong
objectively with this sack well let's
check with the computer
so this is correct
it goes back to g3 already not as good
bishop f4 is a better idea
because the bishop do you see that the
bishop now controls the d2 square so
bishop g3 kind of leaves the queen out
to dry
bishop f6 queen d2 now you can see that
the position is still approximately
equal takes takes rook e8
and here rook d1
is another inaccuracy
king f1 apparently was the best move
what
allowing rookie two
and now oh
my god now rookie one see this is what
i'm talking about who is supposed to
find this
if takes the rookie made this forces the
rook trade
and if rookie oh my god if rookie seven
you take
and now the secondary point you break
the king to e1
and after knight d4 queen d3 apparently
white is fine
so here we go this is how you're
supposed to play chess
i mean king f1 if white plays you can
kind of accuse him of cheating
rook d1
rookie two
queen c1 is another mistake it's too
passive d2
knight d4 we played correctly
rook d8 oh rook d it's a mistake we had
to play rook de7 here
i completely missed this concept of king
f1
like i just didn't see this at all but
here i think it's findable because here
it stops ricky one check
and by playing rookie seven
we are able to meet king f1 with rookie
one chuck winning the game
why not knight b4
because knight before there's just queen
a4
right the knight is better placed on d4
it's more centralized
so rook d8 king g2 and now i played
correctly knight f5
still king f1 apparently equalizes and
bishop f4
yeah and still king f1 at least gives
white some chances so this whole idea of
king f1 to chase away the rook using the
king as a defender
i kind of totally overlooked
and uh after bishop c793 the game is
over
no g5 is decent
but a faster win oh my god knight h4
check
king g3
oh and just rook t3 you go for checkmate
you just go for checkmate
and if king f1
oh this is beautiful look at this
geometry
check
takes takes king takes e1 and what
happens at the end
knight g2 check
picking up the bishop
but most importantly the reason this is
a better version is because you can't
take the pawn to get checkmated
so
crazy concept there with that h4 check
exploiting the undefended bishop
it does look simple when i play but this
isn't even simple for me
yeah so after g5
um king f1
would have forced rookie one check trade
now black takes the bishop now black has
three pieces for the queen but after
queen b5
this is a fork against the knight in the
pawn black's king is not so safe now
that our pawn is no longer on g7 so
white has some off chances to save the
game
white has some off chances to save the
game
so
but still king f1 is not a simple move
in this position counter-attacking the
rook
bishop h4 there's rook takes d2
bishop h4 is a blunder you allow rook
takes d2
and of course as you can understand the
issue is always the back rank just shows
you how important back rank issues are
does that make sense
and you might say well what about rook
takes f2 is in this checkmate
it's not because just king g1 and
there's no more checks
there's no more checks you have to go
back to e2 and basically play this
position
our sexy pawn is lost and white's king
is has not been checkmated
so play h6
writes re in all caps when do you
propose to do that that's the whole
problem you don't have time if you go h6
here then you allow king f1 that's why
it's so important to make love when you
have the chance because at some point if
you procrastinate too long you won't
have the chance that's part of the
reason that i played g5 this also
creates loft
on g7
what if queen a5 after g5 well here we
can go knight h4 check intermezzo
does that make sense you give the check
to the king
and then you can take the bishop because
the bishop defends the rook on the air
maybe you missed that
uh bishop e5
i mean this is bad for a lot of reasons
one of which is 93 check don't forget
about this move that was the whole idea
of knight f5
how come we didn't care about the pawn
no we always cared about the pawn what
do you mean we always cared about it
well come on
why do we care about the pawn woods when
it's on t2
earlier the pawn was on d4 and it was
the early middle game i had no way of
knowing the spawn would be promoted but
as white loses more and more pieces
the chances that the pawn promotes
become greater and greater and once we
sacrifice the queen
the reason we sacrificed it is literally
so that we later in the long run can
promote the pawn
now what's important to understand about
this sacrifice as unsound as it is
it's the fact that we sacrificed
oh i was logged off okay just a second
i i essentially sacrificed for
long-term reasons
and
what's important to understand about
this is
what does that mean what does it mean i
sacrificed for long-term reasons so
it's not like i calculated all this way
and i knew for a fact that i was going
to promote my pawn i made an intuitive
judgment i figured that the
fact that i have these bishops on great
squares
the fact that this pawn is as well
defended as it is
and the fact that the queen is a
terrible blockader
how do i know it's a terrible blockade
well we saw how bad it was you see how
easy the queen is to attack if there was
a knight that was on d2 in this position
you wouldn't have to move the knight but
because there's a queen and the queen is
the most valuable piece it's a huge
liability it can get tossed around so
it's not good as a piece that it's not
good as a door stopper right it's
constantly getting pushed around
potential energy of the pawns
potential activity of the pieces current
activity of the pieces equals
very significant long-term compensation
for the queen
i wouldn't have done the same in a
classical game no no no i would have
gone queendy sound in a classical game i
would have dropped the queen back i also
would have taken a long time i would
have definitely thought about
sacrificing but there's no way i would
have taken that kind of a risk
but this is the speed run and sometimes
i do stuff that i wouldn't always do in
a classical game for illustrative value
it's not like i compromise the result we
still want a game
what's a good book to learn higher
strategy so my favorite is positional
chess for club players
sorry chess strategy for club players is
a great like 400 page book on
all positional themes
so that's a starting point for 13 1400
players and above
so
computer thought the queen sag was a big
mistake i wouldn't say the computer
thought it was a blunder
because a blunder implies that it's like
okay
yeah basically a blunder
computer thought the queen sack is
basically a big mistake
and there are definitions
like you might ask well what's the
difference between big mistake and
blender like i feel like there are
definitions in terms of the evaluation
like how much does the evol change i
would say if the eval changes by two
points or more in most cases it's a big
mistake
if it changes by like three points or
more then you're in blunder territory
but these are like very rough
very rough distinctions it doesn't
matter right big mistake blunder it's
kind of all similar
you kind of know when you've blundered
if you're 500
you need to solve exercises and play
games and analyze them
and figure things out would be a trial
and error
no no ergosphere that's not true
if the computer gives such a drastic
assessment it's not going to change
suddenly at depth 60.
right already on depth 25 it's going to
give you a pretty good ballpark of what
what the assessment is
it might change marginally but it's not
going to change like
globally if that does that make sense
especially in a relatively simple
position like this one there aren't that
many pieces on the board it's pretty
well defined so
the engine is right here alright guys
that was a really nice game i think it
was
instructive full of interesting moments
and i hope you enjoyed it the computer
just never takes into account anything
practical like whether it's
you know like how difficult the position
is to play for a human by definition the
computer doesn't incorporate that into
its judgment that's why it's so
dangerous to use the computer and over
rely on it that's why robert and i are
always on a crusade to get people
uh now if you're a beginner and you're
watching it's understandable why you
would rely heavily on the email bar the
computer assessments but
never fall into the trap of assuming
that just because the top player
you know misses x number of computer
moves per game then that player is bad
all right or or that
you know you you might play better than
that player because it's literally
impossible
to to understand how difficult chess is
when you're just looking at a game of
the computer like because every single
move begins to look obvious every single
computer move you can kind of find a
reason for
and
you know that's a trap
yes the whole cesi says he's plus three
and blundered
hopefully one day maybe with enough
prodding and annoying from me
that will kind of stop and people will
like appreciate on mass
the difficulty of chess and how good the
top players actually are
but that day is a long way away
okay
enough guys i'm gonna get to bed
thanks for hanging out everybody
appreciate it hope you enjoyed
[Music]
you